food
the same will be the case with the other
form of the this
with here here is for example
the tree if i turn around this truth is
vanished and is converted into its
opposite
no tree is here but a house instead here
itself does not vanish on the contrary
it abides
constant in the vanishing of the house
the tree
etc and is indifferently house or tree
again therefore this shows itself to be
mediated simplicity or a universality
in section 98 hagel is stressing to us
that the very same dialectic
that we went through incense certainty
with respect to
the time or the temporality of the
object thinking about
a this in terms of the now
and then realizing that the now can be
noon
or night or three o'clock or 11
11 whatever it is that we want
there's a dialectic involved in that
that shows us that things are much more
complicated than we originally
assume as we're experiencing them as
we're saying this is what is most real
this is what we know
now when we turn to spatiality it gets
even more complicated in some respects
because with time you you just have you
know
now and then you know it's going to be
in the future and that'll be a different
now
and the time stream as we think about is
a whole bunch of now it can get more
complicated than that if you have other
theories of time we're going to try to
avoid that
but think about spatiality you know it's
not a continuum just like
this way and this way already it's
different than
time in that i can move
one way along the spectrum and another
way along the spectrum whereas with time
i'm constantly being launched into the
future the past is constantly receding
behind
behind me i can i can bring it back in
memory but it's not the same thing
with spatiality i can move forward i can
move back
i can go up i can go down we have
three spatial dimensions
so we should think of space less as a
continuum
and more as something like a manifold
and what does that introduce for us that
introduces
a lot more possibilities for what it is
that this
understood now in terms of spatiality is
here
can be so we again we see that same
sort of dialectic playing itself out we
pick something
that is substantive that we can identify
we look at the tree and as a matter of
fact i'm looking out the window at a
tree right now
so we see the tree and
here now becomes that thing impinging
upon us
is that what the here really is is that
what's the truth of self
uncertainty is no because we can shift
our perspective
we can turn away from the tree and now
look at the house
or maybe we only have to turn this far
you know here it could be
i look at the the door i look out the
window i look at the camera i look at
the chalkboard
all of these are possibilities for that
here
so we go through the same sort of
progression except notice in this case
we can even go from there to whatever
else you like
because look up there's a light blazing
in my eyes
now i'm a little bit dazzled
these are all very different experiences
so none of them
is really what the here is
he says all of these are converted into
their opposite if we look at the house
the house is not the tree it's also not
the etc
if we look at the tree the tree is not
the house
it's also not this and whatever this
happens to be whatever extra stuff we
want to
cram in there that's not what these
things are so there's a lot of negation
going on he says
what's going on in this are we losing
the here no here itself does not vanish
as we've seen with
now the here is what remains constant in
all of this here is something that we
can pick out with language
the here is also something that we're
able to think
it is a universal as hegel says
it's mediated simplicity or universality
in this case the this of the here so he
says
it abides constant in the vanishing of
the house the tree
as we move from one object to another
one
experience of something external to us
as being the here or even something that
could be internal like here's a hand
use you know g moore and wittgenstein's
famous example right
any time that we're doing that we're
dealing with something that is
what it is and also is not what it is
because it is being provided to us in
sense certainty
and because the mediating function of
the here
pure being remains therefore as the
essence of this sense certainty
since since certainty has demonstrated
in its own self
that the truth of its object is the
universal
but this pure being is not an immediacy
but something to which negation and
mediation are essential
consequently it is not what we mean by
being
but is being defined as an abstraction
or as a pure universal
and our meaning for which the true
content of sense certainty is not the
universal
is all that is left over in the face of
this empty or indifferent
now and here
in section 99 we're right at the cusp of
a really important transition
in sense certainty and we're sort of
bringing things
to a close or at least to a not as far
as hegel is concerned in this passage
so where are we beginning or where
are we starting from in this
passage from from what's been happening
in the others the
essence of sense certainty has been
revealed as
pure being now why pure being
what we thought we were getting in sense
certainty was beings
that were manifesting themselves to us
as being as
what is and so in any given experience
of that
we have more than one thing going
on when we originally thought we only
had one thing so
we think about this and then this
already starts to split
into here and now or it could be if we
wanted to
there and then as well we could pick
whatever sort of
dictates that we want or or indicator
words
and already we've got a splitting a
spaltum going on
but it gets more complex than that
because as we've seen
with the here the here can be a
multiplicity of different possibilities
it can be a tree it can be a house it
can be the et cetera the
you know vita that uh you know we have
or um the the now can be noon it can be
night it can be whatever we want
so that means that these are universals
and universals we've seen have an
interesting kind of
you know not quality but but status as
we'll talk about in just a moment
so what we've arrived at is the essence
of sense certainty what's really going
on in sense certainty
is that we're encountering pure being
but we're not encountering pure being in
the sense of having some sort of
intuitive grasp
of the hole as such or even with a
particular object i don't grasp the pure
being
of this chalk as just this piece of
chalk where my hand is just my hand
what is going on then well the truth of
the
object the truth of what it is that
we're experiencing
is realized to be the universal
and the universal like he says has
several important
qualities that i've got sort of you know
summed up here
it's something that can be said so i
should have put up there the word
language
it's something that exists
linguistically it can also be thought
because we human beings have the
capacity to think beyond just
particulars and to form universes
what else can't be sensed
so strangely enough while we do
have to experience the here as this spot
here or that spot over there
we can't actually see the here the here
only exists
in the multiplicity of its particulars
it is
and it isn't its particulars it's not
any one of its particulars
but it is all of them at the same time
it is what makes them the kind of
particulars that they are
so we've got this interplay going on
here that we're going to see
happening over and over again throughout
the phenomenology
from certainty we start being concerned
with truth
and the truth helps us to eliminate what
certainty really is
these are not exactly the same thing but
they exist
in a complex mediated relationship
so now when we think about what that
means
that we're grasping pure being we're not
experiencing pure being as such in the
sensual
sensory type of way but we are grasping
pure being
and as hegel says it's worth going back
to the the actual text here he says
we're not grasping it in immediacy
because pure being is not an immediacy
it's rather something
in which we find negation and mediation
occurring
and not just occurring as kind of a
byproduct but as something essential
to the way that pure being is now this
is a somewhat different conception of
being
than would been proposed by
metaphysicians in the past like say
aristotle
or thomas aquinas and it's not quite yet
you know
the being that's going to be proposed by
other later metaphysicians as well but
this
is a quite interesting notion here isn't
it
that pure being as such that we
encounter
as the essence of sense certainty
involves
negation and mediation and its essence
now he goes and he says when we're
talking about
being or pure being
it's not what we actually mean when we
say being
it's not what we intend meinen is the
german term
he's going to play on words with that a
little bit uh in a
few passages down the line
but the mining is is to go back to some
of the other passages before that
that's what we were intending in in
relating ourselves to the object
and in trying to speak it through
language we were intending it and we
were also
uttering it we're out you know we're we
were
you know either zagging or outside the
the object
we were trying to express it is another
way to say
and so being is
in in effect not what we can actually
intend or mean when we say it
instead it's being as an abstraction so
this is going to require
some unpacking he says it's um
being defined as an abstraction the word
there could be understood is
corresponding to an
abstraction as well for which the true
content of censor he is not the
universal
is all that is left over in the face of
this empty or indifferent
now and here what it is that we're
intending
and we're trying to express and
unsuccessfully doing so in part because
the very dialectic built into
uncertainty
some kind of surplus that is more than
just this empty
abstract form of the now or the here or
this
so we want to ask ourselves at this
point well what is going on what have we
not attended to yet where else can we go
with this dialectic
when we compare the relation in which
knowing and the object first came on the
scene with the relation in which they
now stand in this result
we find that it is reversed the object
which was supposed to be the essential
element and set certainty
is now the unessential element for the
universal which the object has come to
be is no longer what the object was
supposed essentially to
be for sense certainty on the contrary
the certainty is now to be found in the
opposite element that is in knowing
which previously was the unessential
element its truth
is in the object as my object
or in its being mine it is
because i know it send certainty then
through
though indeed expelled from the object
is not
yet thereby overcome but only driven
back into the
eye we have now to see what experience
shows us about its reality in the eye
now in section 100 we find that a very
important reversal or shift of
perspective
is being charted out and
what's going on is a move from from here
to here and this is what hagel has said
has actually occurred at this point we
started out in sense certainty
with a sort of priority of the object
over
the knowing subject and a sort of naive
way thinking that
whatever it is that we're apprehending
impinges upon us and imposes itself
upon us upon our consciousness and we
just sort of take it in
and the more passive the more receptive
we are the
truer and the richer that kind of
knowledge will be
and as time goes on we realize that
that's not really the case
so we begin with the object over the
subject you can say the object as what
is essential versus what is inessential
it doesn't matter who the eye is
as a matter of fact if you get rid of
the eye as much as possible
the hope is well now you'll have this
this experience and you'll really be
able to see things
how they are but what we find is that
instead
things are more complex
and what turns out to be in essential is
first the object
which gives way to the universal the
now the this the here whatever it is
that we want to do what we can name in
language
but then there's another
reprioritization that's taking place
the subject the knowing the thinking the
acting subject the experiencer
is the one who's actually running the
show
that's what's been going on all this
time
so the way things were here actually has
to be flipped back upside down
with the object now being a bit more
complex and the subject
as being what is truly essential
and what does that mean for us well like
hegel says it's shown us that there
actually isn't any certainty or truth in
the
object per se of sense certainty
that's where we actually thought we were
going to get certainty
and when we explored what the meaning of
its truth was
we found out that the truth turned out
to be
somewhere else in namely the universal
and that unknows the certainty
of the object for us and we try to be
certain about the universal but the
universal isn't even something
that we can grip onto and say aha now
we've got it
this is the entire sum of what's going
on in this process
the certainty of sense certainty and
here is the
mystery of it that's now being unveiled
lies in the activity of the eye
the knowing or the thinking or the
experiencing subject
so that's a major shift
what this means is that the object
has truth or as its truth
the truth that is appropriate to that
object
only as my object
dear hegel is actually going to have a
sort of play on words going on
he's using this german term mining which
we've discussed already
and minin means intending
you know what we're gesturing at what it
is that we have in mind
um we've already seen the contrast
between intending and expressing our
sagan
but it also has an affinity with with
the
word that's used as a possessive pronoun
mind mining mine
is the cognate in english that which
belongs to me
so by my
intending something in
what i am experiencing in sense
certainty
i am making it mine
i am making it have the truth that
i give to it it doesn't simply have a
truth in and of itself that it imposes
upon me
towards which i have to be completely
passive rather i am
actively engaged in this this very
process
to be able to see it under the guise of
a universal
within the the luminosity or or
intelligibility that a universal
provides i'm the one who's doing that
the i and so sense certainty
is not as he says overcome
or out go home that when we see any
any use of this uh this word alcohol
of hebong or things like that we ought
to be thinking about whether a
you know transition has happened going
to the next stage or not
the next gestalt and he's saying no it
hasn't there's there's still more going
on here
sense certainty has not been alkahoban
but rather it has been pushed back
i should have left that there i thought
it was just some scratches
how ironic huh for for what i'm doing
here
uh it's been pushed back zeruka drinks
it's you know repressed you might even
say
into the eye the meaning of
certainty now resides in the i in the
subject who is
having the sense experience so rather
than the objects out there
being what sense experience is truly
about
it's rather what i am bringing to it
what i am contributing to
what activity of mine it constitutes
so what does this mean for us then well
he tells us
at the very end of this it says
um we now have to see what experience
shows us about its reality
in the eye the what's reality the
reality of sense
a sense certainty of experiencing things
what is the reality of experience
within this eye that now has assumed the
kind of
you know shape or form
of yet another universal yet another
abstraction
because who is this i that we're talking
about that's a key
important topic that we're going to
explore
the force of its truth thus lies now in
the
eye the immediacy of my seeing hearing
and so on
the vanishing of the single now and here
that we mean
is prevented by the fact that i hold
them fast
now is day because i see it
here is a tree for the same reason but
in this relationship sense certainty
expresses the same dialectic
acting upon itself as in the previous
one
this eye i this eye see the tree
and assert that here is a tree
but another eye sees the house and
maintains that here is not a tree but a
house instead
both truths have the same authentication
that is
the immediacy of seeing and the
certainty and assurance that both have
about their knowing
but the one truth vanishes in the other
i've remarked before that it doesn't
take hegel too long
to start introducing new dialectical
movements
within you know whatever it is that
we've we've now achieved some sort of
what appears to be sort of
fixed static point and that's the same
thing that's going to happen
now with the i in this section 101.
so we've established now that the i
is central is essential to what's going
on
in sense certainty and what we have now
is a new immediacy
so whenever you see immediacy by now you
should you know have a
sort of red flags going up if hegel says
that there's something
that presents itself as immediate it's
not going to stay immediate very long
because immediacy is never what truly is
the the case in the galleon system but
we've got this eye
who's now engaging in acts of sense
perception
and seeing and hearing in other senses
and we don't have to worry too much
about
you know how exactly the sensorium works
or anything like that with
inner senses versus external senses
we're not worried about that
so far what we're interested in is the
fact that
what this has achieved for us is it's
attained a kind of
status of providing a resolution to one
of the problems
we've been concerned before about when
it came to the here and the now the this
of said certainty what keeps those
what they are what preserves
their meaning and we have them as
universals and that's fine
but what about their determinate content
well as it's going to turn out
what it is that does that is the i the i
preserves or holds fast or determines
the content if you know where i look
where i keep on looking that determines
the here
then now okay time not quite so much you
have to do a little bit of
stretching with this but you know we can
focus in
on how we understand time
and hegel says that
this is actually an advance so
i determine here as say a tree
right i keep it a tree so long as i've
got my eyeballs looking at it
so long as i determine what it is that
my
senses are taking in it could be that
you know i do that with my tongue too i
go up and lick the tree or something
like that
the bitterness of the the bark or i'm
scratching the tree
and i'm listening to the sound of the
bark and it's you know impinging on my
fingers and
i'm smelling the odor of of you know
freshly peeled birch or something like
that
we can you know go into all sorts of
details but the point is the eye is
actually what is keeping this what it is
he says
um i hold them fast now is
day why because i see it
because i'm there it's day for me
remember we just had this thing about
the mine and the intending
which is also mine so he says i see the
tree and i assert that here is a tree
now we end up in a problem though
and we're going to introduce another
wrinkle to the dialectic and
here hegel is in many respects
prefiguring
what is going to be going on in a much
more famous passage that we'll get to
a much more famous section that we'll
get to later on down the line with
self-consciousness which involves
consciousness of
an other because
you gotta ask yourself well who's this
eye is it me is it you
is it some sort of ghostly spiritual
eye over and above us that we both
somehow partake in
uh you know the form of platonic man or
human being or something like
that no the eye is is an actual
person but then there's another eye
actually a whole world of other eyes
right
and that other eye he says doesn't see
things the same way
well i'm holding fast that you know
sense certainty
uh and here is the tree that other eye
is saying no
it's the house
which of us is right well we're both
right because we're both perceiving it
but then what's the truth of send
certainty
what is really going on in it because i
said well he's perceiving that you're
perceiving that you just have your own
separate perceptions
and you'll say no the capacity
for us to hold this fast opens up a
vulnerability
of our very own selves to others who can
likewise
hold it fast at the same time he says
both truths have the same authentication
the immediacy of seeing and the
certainty assurance that both have about
their knowing
but the one truth vanishes into the
other and we see this
happening when somebody says no you're
wrong you know what we're actually
looking at is is not a tree
it's um a painting
and the one certainty begins to add
and disappear the truth begins to be
lost
in that of the other we can do the same
thing by the way with day and night
all we need to do is
do something that wasn't available for
hegel at the time and communicate across
time zones right
if i'm communicating with somebody on
the other side of the world
and it happens to be day for me right
now maybe it's midnight over there
so the same thing can be done for
temporal as well as spatial and now what
we see
is we have to be concerned about the
relationship
between these two eyes
which both seem to be the eye of sense
certainty